oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the world of virtual
reality I finally have my virtual
lulululu
I finally have my virtual reality set up
all set up and ready to go which means
that I have all the space that I need to
be able to enter the virtual world also
you may notice I got no strings to hold
me down boo badoo badoo badoo diddly
lifts up beep bop bar I'm gonna be doing
a lot of virtual reality but this is
doom VFR and now this just came out I
don't know if it's any good or not I'm
gonna do I played the day I played I did
my let's play of doom oh no oh I did my
let's play of doom on ultraviolence so I
don't know if that's gonna be the right
approach but that's the approach that
I'm gonna be taking ooh yeah that's go
oh these are robes ah hello yeah I'm
sure about that Yama what the hell
everything okay oh gee oh God okay note
to self don't check it
well ah hey good to know oh that's not a
good sound oh [ __ ] hi hello good god hi
okay thank you for that but not o not
alrighty then must have activated the
cognitive Transfer Protocol that hasn't
been done since he didn't of course get
some answers
I knew that Oh sick sleeps casualties
we'll start there uh-oh has to be a
combat chassis somewhere huh that would
work good timing that thing oh okay well
I don't know what's happening
he said the combat chassis proto oh
don't you run from me
listen there's one thing I don't like
and that's people running for me okay
where are you guys by the way am I
looking in the right direction this is
the first thing I've recorded today so I
have no idea if everything is fine or
not but boy I didn't even confirm
nothing oh wow what did i do usually in
these there's a teleport mechanic ah I
understand yes go into the pit ah
oh okay now this time you're not gonna
run for me cuz I'm gonna do one of these
maneuvers oh all right fine
ah there we go I didn't read what it
said ah oh ah that's gonna make me puke
I get it okay I get it ha
oh hey oh no hi Oh what reading is for
nerds the combat chassis is a Koopa
dwith very use weapons using the whoop
and rule you can switch between your
cool boink
ah this Oh wanna do moon is too good
from talking a new moon you can tulip
loot into loot why can i teleport in the
first place hey lesson Sally sue I take
too kindly to your kind of interruptions
I'm gonna go this way now oh I guess I
don't have a gun now who come back
caboose is issue coopered with granado's
yah oh that was a hefty throw hang on I
got a present for you oh come on
okay real gentle-like pad I'm so glad
I'm so strong I show it up there oh I
know oh Jesus I'm so strong who knew oh
Jesus Christmas Oh use the shield boost
ability to push book Newman's that are
surrounding you long nice
plonk nice okay all right Oh she'll
burst
I don't know what shield bursts means
but okay so I have like a shield or
something
ooh oh the organ khushu can upgrade
wound of your three abbulu dues all
right I'm gonna stop doing that that's
officially uh it's officially gotten
annoying hasn't it oh wait it was always
annoying uh my Brad I'm trying to touch
it for some reason I can't touch you Oh
return to play area why what are you
gonna do weird you proud a game nothing
that's right what am i doing what okay
I've got a gun I don't have a gun oh I
point at it that's what I do
Oh slow motion during teleportation well
this seems good I don't even know what
that means but I'm gonna accept it as my
own rude ah very time slow oh yeah all
right weapon OOP groots the weapon
upgrade station allows you to upgrade
one of your weapons I'm dead I'm dead I
died I'm dead oh here I am now I guess
I'm not dead
ooh excuse me I got dangly and got a bad
case of dangle hand I'm gonna go this
way oh let me let me think about that
hmm that's all
Hulu charged and his ass boring I'm at
three round bursts tighter spell I like
I like a tight spread everybody knows
markiplier likes a nice tight spread Oh
congratulations on completing the Kumu
chooses to do real feel free to practice
an experiment with your abilities in
this room when you're ready to return to
reality stand on the teleportation path
sure okay ah oh
Oh time slow huh ha ha ha oh geez oh
geez
are ye oh I see how it'd be okay all
right
Oh what are you gonna do buddy miss me
oh hey all right
okay okay I get it I think I get it
okay I get I got it I got it I got I get
it I get it old do I
woo he said that this hasn't been done
since Aidan which I can only assume
means that they're talking about Aidan
little like director of all this and the
CEO of the UAC and all that jazz which
is fascinating how you doing
are you doing buddy you okay is that my
body I'm assuming I'm in a big metal
chassis like like we had it you know the
other place oh well I got it I'm a
lumbering behemoth okay ah man that is
gonna make me vomit ooh I got it guys I
got it boom guy I'm a hero look at me
eliminate the new oh this should be fun
should it be I died once oh I don't know
if I want to do it again hello hey who's
there huh oh well they're all dying
without me so I guess I'm fine okay
whoa what the hell they're just fighting
each other right hi hi oh jesus that
hurt like a bastard
whoa he's got nobody oh where did you go
come on come on let me let me get that
one let me please
I want it so badly remind me no one okay
Oh Jew close to us is that guy was not
fun I could tell by the cut of his jib I
could tell whoa I gotcha oh okay
alright this is a little more manageable
Wow oh that ain't good
I'm alive I might die I might I might
die actually whoa whoa Wow okay I Wow
what where's my hand we're gonna buy oh
there I am
that was hard that was legitimately hard
I mean number one it's different
experience being in real life quote
unquote virtual reality having to use my
hands and legs and such I'll get it okay
all right let me try the postal there we
go get him from a distance you know how
it'd be time to not suck beak around
quarters shoot from a distance oh I've
got the stratagem okay or do I just let
them fight and hop well this is a lot
easier but a lot less fun yeah I'm bored
okay I'm gonna go back to the shotgun oh
yeah I'll get some oh you want some I
have some here have some whoa I've got a
surplus of it oh wow that that hurts so
bad why does that hurt so bad
I know I'm on a high difficulty but good
god some tells me Oh what did you expect
okay thank you yeah I don't know
honestly we're going there huh what are
we doing all right whoa okay all right
No then I do a [ __ ] throw oh god oh god
oh god oh [ __ ] oh god damn you are god
damn it ow ow ow ow
there we go got it it is really hard to
move where are you oh god that's my
grenade I'm gonna die here we go oh jeez
oh jeez ah gee willikers oh I did it
ah look at me being all skilled in the
such as okay where am I going that way
all right
okay I see oh hey Dan an orange energy
transfer station has been activated whoa
hello
wow that argent reserve station created
a new portal portal isn't closed this
facility will be over long huh
Oh No Oh whatever your day blue is that
turns into the Spider Queen Oh
I'd ever realize how beautiful your eyes
were Oh Oh
Samuel Hayden oh you're so big and
strong
oh but our love can never be
we're both robos from the waist down
oh but our love can transcend robotics
hmm
hey guys room for a third in here nice
feel bad about that one hey guys room
for a third in here no okay that makes
no sense
all right I'm done here all right what
else we go over there hang out wait look
II just look at you mm hello let me get
a look at that ass yep that is an ass
huh you you come come here come here you
let me get a look at that ass
Oh underwhelming at best
all right dude god mm-hmm and
substantial all right okay you guys have
fun
I'm out here where am I going all right
let's go in there the key [ __ ]
well this can't be right ooh boink
go go go little buddy okay see ya
whoa can I follow oh [ __ ] alrighty then
that's a thing oh oh you got it oh thank
you well that was easy
okay thank you little buddy alright
thank you oh yeah
Let Me In bang that's my key card right
there baby
yeah how you doing you all right buddy
hey hey come on now hey cheer up
good luck the Africans back to the
teleporter all right okay well if it's
that easy then
oh good Saul do it oh I guess I will all
right here nah
oh yeah that looks teleporting how do
you need a part oh yeah you do baby
malong all right who wants some anybody
you want some that transfer station
uh-huh our new accumulator could
overload the systems and destroy the
portal uh-huh okay so uh no we built a
few of the accumulators uh hacking into
Hayden's computer is probably the best
way to find one I don't know if we'd
like that too much but okay I'll
teleport there sure yeah okay
take me Oh welcome to the party I don't
know if I'd like that that's a very soma
esque and something tells me that that's
not something I'm gonna particularly do
I okay something tells me there's a bit
of big trouble on the other side of this
guy whoa where the heck did that come
from
Oh boink boink yes please ahh
okay I'm gonna get away from that guy
just hit the damn explode ease I see him
right there there bouquet well that did
nothing for me
just shoot him the Chisholm's all right
that was panic inducing hello what are
you thank you what is it oh never mind
I'm not gonna question this gift from
the gods
hey you want some of this very overkill
I know but I had it and I had to use it
oh yes please baby oh yes please all
right I need health desperately oh and
you max it out that's so kind of you
hello Cole elevator I have a feeling
there's gonna be some in there I've been
feeling I just have a funky filling in
my funky brain damn it got him the worst
of that all right you got it you good
titty sprinkles you got them piece of
[ __ ] all right that is not what I want
to use on that control panel there we go
okay all right we are good who's ready
to say hello to my big friend okay I'm
gonna get this just because my pistol
seems like since it has unlimited ammo
it's probably gonna be something that
I'm gonna be using a lot of so why not
am i right people that is underwhelming
at best all right whatever
hey Sammy boy Sammy boy we just leave
accumulators lying around uh-huh hello
sorry sorry sorry I can't hit anything
anyway so it didn't dude
dick what do we got hacking a cursor
moves back and forth on a roll let her
stop the cursor by pulling the right
trigger it flashes green over a letter
and the cursor precedes to the next row
complete all the rows to win the mini
game win the mini game my favorite thing
I don't know what's happening now I
don't know what's happening okay Oh
ok I get it I get it ok I got it
later is in that prototype cyberdemon
they lost do I have to kill the
cyberdemon because I'm pretty sure I
remember the cyberdemon already being
killed by me and another body and I
don't think you know I don't think it's
fair to the poor cyberdemon that has to
deal with life you know knowing it has
to be embarrassed by two versions of
myself like that's just sad ok alright
ok
dudu dudu delayed oh hello there litter
they did a little litter
ow doodlee do there we go
got him oh that's sure that that's
pretty good that charged shot is
something good that's a slice of
something special all right come at me
you bet oh yeah I forgot I can't do that
to that oh stop tick ok yes let's
ceremonious than I did before
oh that's not good man I need to get my
bigger gun this one whoa Hey
alright now we're getting into it hey
buddy no you know oh yeah you miss nope
I don't think so I don't think so oh
that ain't good
I don't turn so mr. man oh boy wait no
I'm gonna tell him a god damn it
okay all right I had that in the battle
I have no hand there I am apparently oh
there I am
I'm sorry I was trading the wrong way I
had that in the bag on lockdown and it
decided to be a piece of [ __ ] not me
okay I got this
no all right now what I want okay all
right that's important oh boy Wow buddy
out that hurts how that I said that
hurts so that means I should get away
from it huh
oh yeah yeah oh god that's this is a
challenge oh god no oh god oh god
we're okay aah this oh god that's tough
that is ridicu
'that is really tough not a joke where
am I God ow
all right whatever it's it's fine go
stand my ground I got this come on
oh god damn it right into that bowl boy
got that guy not you too whoa got him
okay I got him I got him I didn't know
that I got him [ __ ] dick oh god damn it
really one health oh boy oh boy okay God
god that's annoying that is really
annoying the teleport mechanic is super
not conducive to what we have like the
fast movement [ __ ] I got this I got this
I got this God come on come on all right
I got this not that white this shotgun
is not what I want
oh I want to go to the weapon wheel
please I'm begging you
just why whoa get the weapon wheel oh my
god oh that's so frustrating that's so
frustrating the teleporter is super
inconsistent no now
No no weapon will weapon will weapon are
you [ __ ] kidding me
they're the weapon wheel I push that
button and the weapon wheel I have to
press and then move I get it okay okay
hang on wait no don't don't you [ __ ]
dare
all right now we're getting into
something there okay all right okay all
right okay well all right then
oh boy okay oh that's not all right Wow
okay all right I'm gonna end that there
that's it I could whoa okay so at that
difficulty I can't do that that is just
a an impossibility at that particular
difficulty so that is all the time I
have for this I've actually been playing
it more than I expected to so thank you
everybody so much for watching that was
doom VR the doom experience is not right
to translate to VR because the doom
experience is like very my new controls
that are very precise and the game feel
is very important in VR if you got
really good at this it would still be
frustrating so it's it's good it's kind
of fun but not worth the pain in your
soul so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought of
this down in the comments below and
thanks again for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]